et jean relisons merci de nous
accompagner pendant cette demi heure
êtes élus de moselle membres du groupe
union centriste au sénat vous soutenez
le fc metz puisque vous avez réagi le
coma à la dernière information qui joue
sa survie en ligue 1 oui face au psg les
canes sa lettre ont bloqué à paris qui a
buzzé ça va être compliqué ça va être
compliqué pour lui on imagine que vous
souhaiter évidemment dans une chance au
fc metz on va parler juste avant du
gouvernement jean 1 et visant d'abord
avec vous elisabeth bande qui a donc été
nommé nommé un nouvelle première
ministre c'est un bon choix pour vous
c'est un choix c'est pas une surprise
puisque son nom était évoqué à plusieurs
reprises dans la presse c'est une
personne qui est connue qui vient de la
gauche modérée moi je n'ai pas a priori
de 2,2 d'opposition le principe je suis
pendant la posture d'ailleurs les
centristes ne sont jamais de la posture
mais dont l'analyse des faits tels
qu'ils se présentent à nous on verra on
verra a priori moi j'essaie de bien sûr
bonne chance mais je ne doute pas de sa
volonté de réussir au cas par cas les
centristes ne sont pas dans la posture
du tout ils sont les centres et son
avers v marseille votre président groupe
sur ce plateau la semaine dernière
qu'ils nous disaient que je n'étais pas
fermé à l'idée de travailler avec le
gouvernement est ce que vous êtes en
cours dans l'opposition aujourd'hui où
est ce que vous êtes ouverts à
travailler avec la majorité
présidentielle nous depuis le début
depuis 2010 est d'ailleurs on avait
vocation puisque les centristes
sont sont positionnés comme il le sent
vocation à travailler avec la majorité
présidentielle seulement il se trouve
que manière de faire de du prise de la
république n'est pas toujours
satisfaisantes à nos yeux c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous sommes restés
en retrait mais maintenant on verra mais
au cas par cas on analysera la situation
d'ailleurs on va avoir dans les
prochains jours une réunion notre groupe
pour déterminer la position comprendra
ou pas comprendra aussi vis-à-vis de la
majorité sénatoriale vis-à-vis de l air
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous pourriez ne
plus être un allié dlr ici au sénat est
plutôt vous tourner vers l'art c'est
trop tôt pour le dire
moi je pense que on a bien travaillé
avec nous allier et l'air
mais j'entends que sur certains
territoires il ya des dissonances des
discordances qui ferait que c'est des
choses pourraient changer pour l'instant
ça n'est pas tel qu'on doive changer à
mon avis rapidement et foyen par des
scissions groupe il peut y en avoir des
départs il y en a eu dans d'autres
partis j'observe qu'il ya un mois une
chez nous que dans les autres partis
mais on verra il faut il faut garder la
tête froide et voir les choses à mesure
qu'elles se dérouleront mai et pas deux
principes d'opposition systémique à
monsieur macro est ce que vous
souhaiteriez que des sénateurs
centristes ont trop gouvernement puisque
la gouverne la composition du
gouvernement va être connus dans les
prochaines heures a priori je suis tu le
mets je souhaite le meilleur pour mes
collègues si le meilleur c'est d'être
ministre qu'il le soit elisabeth bornes
ce n'est pas digne élu local
contrairement à jean castex
contrairement à elle doit aussi des
plats emmanuel macron a nommé une
première ministre qui n'est pas élu
local c'est un problème
peut-être parce que l'élu local présente
à caractéristiques du bien connaître les
réalités territoriales
alors je ne dis pas que mon âme bornes
ne les connais pas à manger elle est
venue à plusieurs reprises en moselle
elle me semblait pas être totalement
déconnecté du territoire mais la force
des élus locaux c'est précisément leur
bonne connaissance des territoires et
des réalités qui s'y trouvent ça veut
dire que on a vu un évidement cette
campagne présidentielle et le vote a mis
en lumière une fracture qui était
évidemment existantes a remis en lumière
jamais une fracture est ce que les
abeilles bornes qui n'est pas élu local
peut être à même de résoudre ces
fractures territoriales
en tout cas elle est bien placée
maintenant elle n'agira peut-être pas
seul puisque bien sûr il ya le prix
gilles la république qui fixe les
grandes orientations
qui n'est pas élue locale
et met une fois de plus on verra un
usage moi j'espère que cette fracture
territoriale qui ce qui ce qui se
maintient qui et qui parfois même
se renforce sera progressivement une
priorité pour le pouvoir en place
puisque les territoires et ressources de
plusieurs mots pour en débattre tout est
justement on va en parler tout de suite
de ces maux dont souffrent les
territoires ruraux et pour ça on va
accueillir notre journaliste
parlementaire mario bigras
bonjour n'arrivons jours ryan bonjour
monsieur maison on va parler de
plusieurs dossiers qui concernent
évidemment les territoires ruraux mais
pour commencer avec vous marion va se
pencher sur la problématique des déserts
médicaux ça fera partie des dossiers
chauds pour nouveau gouvernement
effectivement et on se souvient que
pendant la campagne des présidentielles
tous les candidats se sont emparés de ce
sujet puisqu'il est extrêmement
concernant pour tous les français et pas
seulement pour ceux qui vivent en zone
rurale il est parfois tout aussi
difficile de trouver des médecins et de
se faire soigner en zone urbaine un
exemple le journal le sud-ouest nous
apprenait hier que le service des
urgences du chu de bordeaux est
tellement saturé qu'il va fermer la nuit
ce les cas les plus graves
arrivée par le samu seront acceptées une
situation liée au manque de personnels
hospitaliers associé à l'afflux de
patients non urgents qui ne trouvent
plus de médecins en ville et qu'il faut
donc contenir et bordeaux n'est pas une
exception toutes les régions sont
aujourd'hui concernées par des
fermetures de services d'urgence et
marion dans certaines zones rurales où
la désertification médicale est présente
depuis plusieurs années bien on
s'organise pour un même service de chant
oui et nous avons un plus
particulièrement pu le constater dans
votre région grand est en
meurthe-et-moselle marne et meuse pas
très loin de en haute-marne et meuse pas
très loin de chez vous trois
départements qui souffre d'un déficit en
médecins et plus particulièrement en
spécialiste en six dans le sud meuse 10%
des habitants par exemple n'ont plus de
généralistes et face à cela depuis 2018
les trois territoires bénéficier d'un
soutien financier de 24 millions d'euros
de l'état via la banque des territoires
pour développer sur dix ans une
politique de santé numérique le
dispositif s'appelle i meuse santé et
porte deux objectifs favoriser le
maintien à domicile en développant la
téléassistance ou la télésurveillance et
ramener des services là où il y en a
plus j'ai la téléconsultation à ligny en
barrois dans la meuse où nous nous
sommes rendu un service de télé
consultation a été installé dans un
bâtiment france service une infirmière
est présente pour accueillir les
patients et faciliter les échanges avec
le médecin toutes les données médicales
lui sont transmises les consultations
sont ouvertes à toutes les pathologies
sauf les enfants de moins de 3 ans pour
qui un examen clinique reste nécessaire
en cas de doute andy caustique sur un
diagnostic le médecin peut également
disposer d'un médecin de soutien qui
recevra le malade alors il ya deux
intérêt à la téléconsultation le premier
peut-être le plus important c'est
d'abord permettre aux gens de continuer
à se soigner malgré l'absence de
médecins de proximité et je vous propose
d'écouter à ce sujet le témoignage du
docteur kern que nous avons rencontrés
lors de notre reportage
de bière je vois un patient qui arrêtait
touchons traitement antihypertenseur
depuis deux mois dans un secteur où il
ya plus du tout deux médecins
et deux mois sans antihypertenseurs
évidemment il avait interne selon
lui c'est il ya des endroits où vraiment
on sent que ça fait longtemps qu'ils
appelèrent en châtain et là on se dit
que il ya du travail et une étude ifop
publiée en janvier dernier révélait que
70% des français ont déjà dû renoncer au
moins une fois à se faire soigner faute
de délai de coups ou de distant
jean-marie misons est ce que c'est une
problématique vous rencontrez également
sur votre territoire territoire voisin
de l'ami lui tout à fait là ce
département de la moselle ne fait pas
exception il est également concernée par
ce qu'on appelle les déserts médicaux en
plusieurs endroits pas seulement comme
vous le disais tout à l'heure au milieu
rural également obligé au milieu plus
urbanisées c'est la même difficulté que
les gens rencontrent et des initiatives
sont prises le divers de diverses des
divers ordres jeux jeux par exemple y
avait des des cabines des télés pour la
télémédecine je sais que en moselle il
ya des pharmaciens qui investissent et
qui mettent en place des cabines
chercher dans ces pharmacies pour
apporter leur leur unis 7 leur
contribution à
ce fléau il ya aussi des initiatives
publiques qui sont prises par des
intercommunalités pour aller dans ce
sens ma foi les initiatives sont de
divers ordres un concours tout à faire
en sorte que la solution soit un peu
meilleur
demain que que hier il ya d'autres
solutions l'autre enjeu est évidemment
marion c'est de permettre à de jeunes
médecins médecins de venir s'installer
dans ces zones rurales avec évidemment
une garantie de clientèle oui et pour y
parvenir le gouvernement propose de
verser des bourses étudiantes en échange
de l'installation dans une zone reculée
de soutenir le développement des maisons
santé de déléguer certaines tâches
médicales à d'autres professionnels vous
l'évoquez comme les pharmaciens ou les
kinés pour mieux répartir la prise en
charge des malades et enfin on parle
désormais également beaucoup d'une
quatrième année d'internât à effectuer
en milieu rural que pensez vous de ces
premières pistes tracées par le
gouvernement elles vont dans le bon sens
mais reprendre le dernier exemple que
vous évoquez encore faut-il pour que ce
stage soit validée que le le sager
puisse s'appuyer sur un médecin aurait
parfois certaines gens il ya plus de
médecins vous savez la question de
garantir le salaire même des communes
ont fait ce choix la commune dans
laquelle j'étais maire a dû garantir à
la demande du médecin qui voulait
s'installer un médecin hospitalier qui
n'avaient pas de patiente elle a dû
garantir sa son salaire pendant un an on
n'a pas hésité à le faire dieu merci on
n'a jamais eu à débourser le moindre
euro parce que tout de suite tant la
demande est forte il a il a atteint le
niveau du salaire qu'il avait proposé
mais des initiatives viennent de partout
tant le problème est prégnant et les
gens ils sont très très sensible est-ce
que parmi les initiatives liberté
d'installation des médecins et les
comprendre alors on me dit on me dit moi
j'étais tenté de le penser mais on me
dit que ça n'est pas
ça n'est pas efficace que la médecine
libérale suppose une la liberté dont
toute l'action qui est la sienne et que
donc ça serait un peu antinomique avec
avec cette volonté de le garder médecine
de libéro mais j'avais tendance à penser
comme aux données lorsqu'on arrive à des
situations et les écarts sont tellement
forts on peut pas avoir des zones
surdotées et de zones trop sous-dotées
qu'on pouvait prendre des mesures
plus coercitives mais il semblerait que
là où ça a été essayé ça n'a pas
fonctionné merci mario à tout à l'heure
et entame on parlera d'écologie avec
vous dans le club des territoires on va
continuer à parler de ces sujets qui
concernent la ruralité parmi les autres
sujets qui inquiètent et la question des
services publics du manque notamment de
service public dont beaucoup de
territoires ruraux ils n'y ont pas accès
et en plus il ya une multiplication des
démarches numérique alors pour tenter de
faire face à ce manque de services
publics physique mais du coup il ya un
problème dont on parle peu c'est
l'électro nisme et pourtant plusieurs
millions de français sont concernés par
ce problème c'est à dire l'incapacité
finalement à se servir des outils
numériques vous avez travaillé sur ce
sujet au sénat vous présidiez la mission
est ce que les choses ont avancé depuis
alors les choses ont avancé
mais mais ce n'est pas une surprise
elles ont avancé lentement quand vous
devez mettre à niveau au niveau des
usages du numérique plus de 13 millions
de personnes on comprend qu'il faut du
temps ça ne se fait pas par un simple
claquement de doigts
le paradoxe c'est que en dépit de cette
situation le gouvernement
maintient sa volonté de voir les 250
démarches les plus courants tant pour
les entreprises que pour les
particuliers être numérisés au plus tard
au 31 décembre de cette année moi je je
l'inviterai à faire a observé un
décalage puisque c'est c'est compliqué
les jeux sont en souffrance les gens le
vivent mal et se soit complètement
écarté de la société n'ont pas accès à
leurs droits comme il le souhaiterait et
ils s'en plaignent moi je pense que des
initiatives par exemple la mise en place
des conseillers numérique qu'on avait
proposé dans la mission que dans
laquelle
que le jeu que j'avais plaisir de
présider sont une bonne chose seulement
la plus la moitié sont en place il reste
encore un certain nombre d'entre eux à
former je crois près de près de mille
1000 1500 petits sur les 4000 il faut
les former eux-mêmes et ensuite ils vont
aller sur le terrain et tout ça ça prend
un certain temps ça il ya une inertie
naturel qu'on peut pas mettre un système
aussi lourd si rapidement ce qui fait
que ce set ce décalage entre la volonté
d'imposer la systématisation du
numérique sur sept toutes ces démarches
et le le niveau de connaissance et
habitants
ne n'est pas satisfaisant
beaucoup celui qui part donc en jeudi 13
millions c'est ce qu'ils sont totalement
déconnectés mais quand on prend ce qui
ont du mal sens pas à l'aise avec le
numérique ce qui quand ils vont sur le
site de pôle emploi de la caf des impôts
qui rentre un chiffré qui se rendent
compte c'est pas le bon qui veut le
changer et qui ont du mal alors on parle
il ya près de la moitié des français qui
sont concernés que sont pas à l'aise
quoi et sur la question du manque de
salles historiques alors le gouvernement
vont beaucoup ces maisons français avait
cinq qui ont été mises en place pour
pallier ces manques de service public
est-ce que c'est suffisant ou est ce
qu'il faut aller plus loin écoutez moi
je pense que de manière générale
j'espère que jamais on n'aura que des
relations numériques pendant encore des
relations de présentiel
le
la difficulté du monde rural c'est qu'il
a vu effectivement
disparaître notamment ce réseau des
finances publiques les agences les
réseaux de la poste les commerces les
banques tout tout temps beaucoup de
dents de 2,9 de services publics et
privés ont fermé et ça s'est très mal
vécue par les habitants donc les maisons
les france services viennent compenser
mais ne sent pas de nature à pair à à
composer suffisamment une réponse mais
c'est une réponse partielle puisque vous
parlez de financement sur les finances
locales ça aussi c'est important là pour
le cautionnement inquiétude pour les
élus locaux est ce que pour vous il va
falloir rapidement parmi les priorités
du gouvernement une réforme de la
fiscalité locale sympa un serpent de mer
la totalité
d'abord je vous rappelle que monsieur
macron lorsqu'il était candidat york un
peu de temps a annoncé un effort de 10
milliards en direction des collectivités
il n'est pas aller plus avant dans son
explication c'est pas si ça prendra la
forme des contrats de cahors il
s'apprend dans la forme d'une baisse
limitée les
voilà où ça va prendre la forme d'une
baisse des dotations on verra c'est pas
c'est inquiétant en tout cas c'est un
sujet dont le monde des collectivités
locales est ce qu'il faut ensuite
l'allée vers certaines réformes certains
clarification aujourd'hui la dgf plus
personnel
de fonctionnement par dont plus personne
ne sait ce qu'elle recouvre exactement
plus de trente paramètres sont pris en
compte pour définir le montant qui
reviennent à chaque commune on sait pas
expliquer les écarts que qu'on constate
entre certaines communes qui en tout en
apparence les mêmes caractéristiques
donc c'est un système qui est de plus en
plus mal compris et qui donc il faut le
changer j'ai cru comprendre sur les
dernières semaines du 2 du du monde à
deux pas du mandat de la fonction de
madame jacqueline gourault que les
choses allaient normalement dans ce sens
j'espère que ça ne se fera pas enveloppe
égal vous qui connaissez bien c'est ce
que vous redoutez un retour des jaunes
en tout cas d'un mouvement qui exprime
la colère d'une
c6 si effectivement les choses ne
s'arrangent pas notamment en ce qui
concerne l'augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat le risque effectivement fort
pour moi que ça je vous rappelle pour
moi que ça le lait le mouvement s'était
enclenchée il ya à peine deux ans ouais
donc le risque est est encore là on va
justement on retrouve hervé bosio qui
est journaliste au républicain lorrain
bonjour hervé merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous ce matin et vous allez nous parler
d'un dossier qui va forcément intéressé
le sénateur vous revenez sur les
investissements étrangers dans le grand
test et notamment sur un énorme projet
d'autoroute
alors absolument les deux les deux étant
liés le projet d'autoroute n'est
destinée aux étrangers mais
on revient effectivement sur une
excellente nouvelle qui est celle du
dynamisme d'investissements étrangers un
grand test et singulièrement en moselle
en 2021 grand s est classé troisième des
régions d'accueil et des projets
étrangers en france juste derrière le
leader français et auvergne rhône-alpes
en croissance de près de 40% donc au
total 52 52 projets de création 143
projets au total comme celle par exemple
de la reprise de de vitesse coûte
technologie sur le canon que ma chemise
on connaît bien par le chinois cnooc a
permis à elle seule de préserver une
centaine d'emplois ce qui est quand même
considérable dans le seul département de
la moselle au total dix-neuf nouveaux
projets concrétisés sur cette seule
année pour un total d'investissements
857 millions c'est à jouer patrick
weiten le président du conseil
départemental ya peu une attractivité
qui est très dynamique donc à laquelle
concourent notamment et de manière très
directe la qualité des infrastructures
de transport et en la matière le sillon
mosellan dossier de poing dans les
tuyaux c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est celui-là 31 un axe autoroutier sur
lequel circulent il ya cent mille
véhicules par jour aujourd'hui en
moyenne sur le seul tronçon sms
luxembourg qui est donc sursaturé et qui
fait aujourd'hui l'objet d'un projet de
nouveau tronçon dia 31 bis entre entre
richement et la frontière
luxembourgeoise justement alors
plusieurs tracés sont encore sur la
table sur lesquels des études sont eux
sont aujourd'hui en cours mais des
tracés qui sont tous encore un porteur
de débats plus ou moins vifs voire de
polémique pour pour certains d'entre eux
leur chemise on à ma question est la
suivante alors qu'une nouvelle phase ii
concernant de concertation pardon public
s'ouvrir à l'automne prochain avec le
début des travaux et carlos ceron en
2030 avez vous le sentiment que le débat
et le dossier avance et qu'il avance
suffisamment vite
alors ça fait ça fait quand même
quelques décennies que ce sujet est sur
la table mais les choses je dois le
confesser avance et nous sommes
maintenant au trou à la concertation sur
les quatre tracés restants je vous
rappelle qu'il y en avait bien plus à
l'origine et il se concentre sur le
passage par par florange
oh
et donc après cette consultation il y
aura une enquête publique mais la
certitude c'est que le tracé le plus
lemoine nuisibles il est en tunnel
profond et il risque d'être tellement
cher qu aucun concessionnaire
ne serait intéressé pour pour le mener à
bien ça c'est le risque et que donc on
soit obligé de revenir à un tracé moins
satisfaisant sur le plan environnemental
mais plus équilibrée sur le plan
économique on verra c'est trop tôt pour
le dire la concertation puis l' enquête
publique et les études qui seront menées
parallèlement nous apporterons les
réponses sur ce sujet mais à ce stade on
a écarté au cas des quatre tracés qui
ont été retenus par les élus est sous
l'autorité du préfet il ya maintenant
près de deux mois on va parler d'un
autre sujet avec vers vc avesnes
questions là-dessus
question particulière le livret condé on
est à un point d'eux
du débat qui
les choses sont encore sur la table et
relativement ouverte parler des
législatives alors la moselle
oui alors en moselle comme comme
ailleurs la campagne des législatives
bat son plein un département qui compte
neuf circonscriptions qui en 2017 avait
envoyé huit députés la république en
marche ou modem et un député les
républicains à la chaux alors depuis
cinq années sont passées et les
résultats du scrutin du dernier scrutin
présidentiel ont donné des ailes à une
formation politique en l'occurrence le
rassemblement national puisque marine le
pen est arrivé au second tour en tête
dans cinq de ses de ces neuf
circonscriptions alors jordan bar des
halles le président du renne qui était
un intérieur lundi dernier ne s'est
d'ailleurs pas privé d'affirmer des
ambitions de sa formation pour les 12 et
19 juin prochains des ambitions qui sont
notamment importante et bien tout près
de votre commune monsieur lisons dans la
8e circonscription au nord du
département de la moselle ces deux
contributions la ville centre à hayange
et déjà tenu par le fn depuis 2014 est
ou sera candidat laurent jacques aubé
dit le chef de file les allures et non
grand test et porte parole de marine le
pen lors de la dernière campagne
présidentielle en tandem avec le maire
d'ailleurs justement fabien fabien
engelmann il ya également une point
d'attention particulier sur la 7e
circonscription à saint-avold où le
rassemblement national parachute
alexandre lebel directeur de la
communication du parti de grosses
ambitions du rassemblement national en
moselle pensez vous c'est déterminant
qu'il existe une probabilité importante
de voir un ou des députés et rennes
mosellan à l'assemblée nationale le mois
prochain bah vous disiez vous même
monsieur jojo quand on attend député la
probabilité de reperdre est plus fort
quand on a peu et donc je pense
qu'effectivement dans ces deux
territoires que vous évoquez temps sur
la huitième c'est à dire hayange que sur
la septième jeu c'est-à-dire saint-avold
le risque de
pour
la république en marche et apporte et
efforts mais on ne peut pas se fier
qu'aux chiffres
parce que la l'élection législative
reste néanmois un concert à caractère de
proximité et moi j'observe que des élus
qui sont investis qui sont très calmes
ans sur le territoire qui sont proches à
l' écoute des gens peuvent obtenir des
résultats très très différent de ce à
quoi on pouvait s'attendre
c'est le cas de
de certains députés qui sont qui sont
vraiment omniprésent et c'est le cas
aussi de certains concurrents sur
d'autres territoires qui en fait une
campagne qui a démarré depuis longtemps
qui hanta à un taux de pénétration très
fort sur leur circonscription et qui
peuvent aussi il a créé la surprise même
si les chiffres en faveur de la
république en marche est né était très
très bons sauts sur ces territoires
le facteur proximité sur la 7e
circonscription on a un parachutage en
bonne et due forme à celui d'alexandre
roubaix qui a qui n'a aucun lien avec
avec le territoire précédemment est-ce
que vous pensez que ça peut jouer en sa
défaveur mais en même temps ce
parachutage comme il fallait s'y
attendre divise le rassemblement
national de la circonscription et c'est
pas bon signe pour pour lui
au
delà de ça je ne sais pas dire qu'il va
gagner on verra ça le 12 et 19 juin
prochain du coup on verra ça avec hervé
évidemment merci beaucoup énervé d'avoir
été avec son regard de la une du
républicain lorrain a31 bis quelle voie
suivre c'est la question à la une de
votre journal merci à vous de jouer
merci jean marie migeotte avec nous pour
cette première demi-heure dons
[Musique]